like ladies where are we at in
objectifying women is that bad that's
tough because some women will say don't
ever objectify a woman but then ladies
you guys do it all day long anytime a
woman posts a picture on Instagram Every
Girl's like beautiful stunning gorgeous
sexy never seen a woman ride smart
interesting
then I've noticed ladies you don't like
when men objectify women if they're hot
but if they're traditionally
unattractive you'll love it smoking hot
girl walks in damn she's sexy as hell
easy creep
but if a lady rolls in on a rascal
scooter with an eye patch damn she's
sexy as hell this is a great guy right
here
but isn't he still a creep lazy if
you're not threatened you're on board if
a guy puts up a poster in his cubicle a
bunch of big breasts and swimsuit models
jeez you pig oh no they're trans hey
good for you
but isn't he still a pig is that a
Victoria's Secret poster on your wall
yeah but it's one with Down Syndrome
okay carry on carry on look why does
that make it okay